so the question is if you're really
concerned about so-called gun violence
and we are everybody should be thousands
of americans die because they're shot to
death every year mostly in our cities if
that bothered you those are your
constituents for example or if you're
just a decent person and cared about
human life
then you would do something about the
violence where it was occurring
but they're doing the opposite they're
letting gun criminals off in city after
city across america buck sexton has been
following this shocking trend he's
hosted the clay travis and buck sexton
show former cia officer we're happy to
have him buck thanks so much for coming
on so how can you scream about gun
violence and then
as a matter of policy let gun criminals
go
well this all stretches back years now
to the end mass incarceration talking
point that progressive prosecutors
whether it's krasner gascone
you name it kim fox in chicago san
francisco philadelphia new york city
look at the prosecutors in all these
places they were talking about ending
mass incarceration so that just meant
bring down the number of people overall
just irrespective of anything else that
are in their county and and city prisons
and what we've seen on the gun front
specifically is a lot of diversion
program a lot of dropping of the charges
in the case of philadelphia you had more
than half last year and this is on the
philadelphia d.a website you can go
check it out more than half of
prohibited possessors meaning people who
were previously criminals or not allowed
to even have a firearm they had their
cases dismissed entirely so these are
often going to be people that have
already had a criminal record that are
under no circumstances able to be
carrying a gun they're carrying a gun
illegally and they just make the charge
go away same thing in new york city our
friend joe borelli of staten island had
a great piece in the post looking at how
of about 4 500 gun arrests in new york
city about a thousand of them something
like 900 and change effectively were
made to go away and they're either going
for lesser sentences they're going for
plea bargains for much lower charges
saying oh it's a minor drug charge well
actually you just decided not to charge
the gun crime they're doing this time
and time again and it's because they
don't want to be seen to be coming down
too hard disproportionately on
communities where there's already
unfortunately far too much gun violence
yeah but you know letting violent people
with firearms walk doesn't help the
population or cities people who are
already
bearing the brunt of this it's amazing
when they're talking about magazine
restrictions and gun show loopholes we
all know that most of the vons first of
all is coming from it's coming from
handguns it's related to criminal
activity a lot of it is gang violence
and it's centered majorly in in cities
all across the country so if you wanted
to do something about that you would
think you would handle more the criminal
element through the judicial process
through the criminal justice process
what we've seen the district attorney's
office in new york is a perfect example
of this and people have kind of woken up
to this now tucker they have made it so
hard and so onerous to prosecute lower
level gun crimes meaning possession
lower level crimes across the board
intentionally that they have to let a
lot of it go effectively stop
prosecuting people because that will
make us safer right so
our voters get guns yours don't i mean
we've seen this before that's that's
what this is buck sexton i appreciate
you coming on thank you thanks tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight